for weeks EU leaders have been mulling
over how best to solve the energy crisis
some member states have already
announced plans to help their people now
the European commission has followed
suit we are proposing a cap on the
revenues of companies that produce
electricity at low costs
these companies are making revenues they
never accounted for they never even
dreamed of
and don't get me wrong in our social
market economy
prophets are okay they are good
but
in these times it is wrong to receive
extraordinary record revenues and
profits benefiting from war and on the
back of our consumers
in these times prophets must be shared
and channeled to those who need it most
but capping the price of Russian gas is
not part of this plan because EU leaders
could not agree what they are proposing
is a windfall tax on the electricity
generators their aim is to raise around
140 billion dollars and give it to the
member states above all they want
everyone to consume as little energy as
possible because many EU leaders want to
break their Reliance on Russian fossil
fuels
we are worried about how to become
independent from gas imports from Russia
they have determined the supply
situation in Germany to a far too large
extent in recent years and decades and
that's why it was necessary for us to
ensure it the greatest possible speed
that we become independent of them
part of the economy drive means people
doing without things that aren't
absolutely essential
from the first day of autumn at 10 pm we
will turn off the lights in public
buildings this will allow us to reduce
the bill the lighting of the Eiffel
Tower will end at 11 45 PM when the
tower closes the end of the illumination
will be time to coincide with the
Public's visits which will reduce energy
consumption symbolically it's important
and yet symbolism in September may not
help keep people warm in Winter right
now EU gas storage facilities are around
85 percent full a figure some say will
be enough for most countries to last to
the end of the year
what they will do in January and
February is not yet clear Dominic Kane
Al Jazeera Berlin